okay question for greg from ryan w and
ryan is a tall person he is six
foot seven or approximately two meters
for our friends that use the metric
system
and ryan's question is um his bmi has
always put him
on the high side of overweight at 250
pounds
and basically the root of his question
is is the bmi skill built
for normal height people basically is
his height
biasing his bmi and making it seem like
he's more overweight
than he should be based on bmi
yeah so probably
something you need to know about the bmi
scale is it was
developed in the 1830s by uh
lambert adolph jacques quitlette
uh i hope i'm pronouncing that right
anyway adolf wetland that's how we're
going to say his name on the show
so anyway uh his name's not that
important the most important thing is it
was developed in the 1830s
and uh when he was you know
looking so it was developed based on
dissected corpses and based on the
dissected corpses that he looked at
uh and just kind of some knowledge of
how
humans scale as they get bigger uh he
was like you know
uh height or weight certainly doesn't
scale
one to one with height
[Music]
it seems to be somewhere between second
order and third order
so you know weights seems to scale with
height squared or height cubed
realistically
probably somewhere in between if i had
to pick an ideal number it probably
scales with
height raised to the 2.5 power
but it seems to be maybe a little bit
closer to two than three
so for bmi it's just going to be you
know body mass in kilograms divided by
height in meters
squared but even when it was developed
he was like
you know 2.5 would probably be a little
better but like i said the important
thing is developed in the 1830s
not everyone had ti 89 graphing
calculators back then
and certainly didn't have a calculator
on their phone in their pocket at the
time
and so it was really easy to raise stuff
to the second power
really easy to raise stuff to the third
power uh
a non-negligible computational challenge
to raise something to the
two and a half power um so bmi
was developed as you know mass divided
by height to the second power
and that's what it is but even when it
was developed it was known
uh it's probably not perfect so the
reason why this is relevant
is the um the impact of
scaling height to the wrong like with
the wrong exponent
isn't going to matter all that much for
people who are normal height which is
you know kind of for whom the formula
was developed
but it's going to matter more and more
for people who are either
way way considerably shorter than
average or
way way considerably taller than average
so
to use the example of ryan w
who asked this question he's
approximately 2 meters tall
and approximately 115 kilograms
so if we plug that into the current bmi
formula
115 divided by 2 squared he comes
out with a bmi of almost 29
28.75 however if we use
what was you know at the time believed
to be a more appropriate exponent in
which
i believe current like like
ongoing science has found is probably a
better exponent
of 2.5 like height raised to the power
of 2.5 rather than 2.
his bmi then would be 20.3
which is normal and so i i think that
you say 20.3 yeah wow
yeah i mean for someone two meters tall
that makes it
that's a big difference um so
so yeah and i mean if you've if you've
ever seen someone who's
six foot seven or two meters tall who
weighs 250 pounds or about
115 kilos like that
to my eye is a healthy weight on that
frame um
so anyway yeah um so it at six
at six seven two fifty you're probably a
perfectly healthy weight
and bmi is probably telling you you are
heftier than it likely should be telling
you
based on the fact that bmi was developed
at a time when
computational power was severely limited
so they just developed a formula that
worked well for people who are around
average height
it probably cuts the other way for
people who are
considerably shorter than average so
one one thing which i guess is important
um is that like kind of normal body
height
is able to skew high much easier than it
is
able to skew short unless someone has
dwarfism
of some of some sort but you know kind
of normal height for
people goes all the way down to you know
maybe 5 foot 3 for
a woman on the shorter side of things
but not an outlier by any
by any stretch of the imagination up to
about
6 2 ish 6'3 for men
so you can skew higher than that pretty
easily like there's a lot of people
without developmental conditions who are
six seven six eight six nine all the way
up to seven foot who don't maybe have
gigantism
there aren't that many people who are
like four foot five without some form of
dwarfism
so it's probably not as extreme for
really short people as it is for really
really tall people
but it probably does cut the other way
as well where there's
you know some people who are four foot
eleven five feet tall
that bmi says are normal weight who are
maybe overweight
um but yeah so it's just purely uh
purely a matter of the the exponent
not being perfect for the bmi formula
works reasonably well for most people
probably doesn't work great for
super jacked people overall in general
but in terms of even
general population works
much more poorly for people who are very
very tall
and likely very very short as well i've
got a slightly related
i wouldn't say rant but i would say
tangent it is kind of wild when you
think of
the number of things that we still use
and the reason we use them is because of
computational limitations that no longer
exist
for sure but we haven't updated it you
know so like like bmi
we could do better but we don't um
why does everybody use a p-value of 0.05
well because at a certain point they had
to print tables
of either 0.0.01.05 or whatever you know
that's why we had specified cutoffs and
didn't just say we'll just report your
p-value
as a continuous number well we can
very easily report exact p-values now
extremely easily
but we still treat it as a very very
very rigid cut off
you know um there's one other i had in
mind
oh yeah we talked about bayesian
statistics a couple episodes ago got a
lot of
surprisingly positive feedback on that i
think so i think people are trolling us
but um you know like when when you lay
it out
um in terms of the the general concept
of what each approach is doing
bayesian brings a lot to the table but
frequentist
methods became like the way to do it
because the computation
was a lot more straightforward before
our computational capacities caught up
but still it's like once something is
ingrained based on prior
computational difficulties it's very
hard to get that inertia
to budge yeah i mean as long as
something works
well enough under most
contexts uh there's gonna be a lot of
inertia
so i mean if if for some reason
um the human population had another
explosion in height
as the one that occurred during the like
early and middle part of the 20th
century
and you know the average human height
became
six foot five guarantee you we would get
an update to the bmi formula pretty
quickly
but for the time being you know it
doesn't work great for a non-negligible
amount of people but it works
you know pretty well for 90 95 of people
so there's just not that much energy
pushing for
for it to change um similar with
frequentest statistics like
they have issues but like they seem to
generally work well enough
most of the time for most applications
so yeah people
just roll with them um
but yeah and i mean of those examples
dog
like bmi is way more egregious than
frequent
versus bayesian statistics because you
know you still
kind of need to understand bayesian
statistics and
like there's it's not something that's
like super straightforward but like
you know literally the only difference
between
the current bmi formula and what would
probably be
a better bmi formula is like
when you type in divided by height
squared just add 0.5 to the end of it
and you know that that's going to take a
quarter of a second
on literally every calculator in the
world um
but yeah people just don't do it do you
think if we started over if we started
fresh today
and said how are we going to do this
data analysis thing
do you still think we would lean toward
frequentist over bayesian
if you ignored the the past history of
using it so much
that's a good question um
i think we'd probably go bayesian i
think we would too just because like
a bayes factor is so much more
explicitly interpretable than a p-value
is
yeah i think it would be um
just more like inherently appealing and
understandable to people
just learning about statistics i agree